joe biden he's the elderly man
pretending to be president of the united
states and we know he puts on masks when
he's doing certain speeches but then
when he walks up and talks to little
children after he takes the mask off he
usually sniffs their hair there was
another video of that this weekend too
we didn't even want to show it to you
it's just so gross
but you know the things just become
complete and ridiculous theater well joe
biden went to eat with dr jill biden and
she's a doctor so she would know about
the efficacy of masks they went to eat
at a very very exclusive very expensive
restaurant in dc where you know when
you're walking to your table as you know
to be a good
safe american you have to put your mask
on well when joe was leaving he wasn't
wearing his mask here's nine seconds of
videotape
there he is and he's holding his mask
and you saw dr jill and you know their
lackeys are behind them and they're
wearing the masks anyway it's not that
this is just such a big deal but it's
like joe is not afraid of catching covet
i don't know how many booster shots he's
had and all of that stuff he's 78 years
old you would think in a public place
the most powerful man in the united
states would be very cautious wouldn't
the doctor
you know the white house doctor be
telling him exactly what to do wouldn't
his secret uh secret service guys you
know wouldn't they be like uh mr
president you forgot to put your mask on
not only is it a violation of the dc
regulation so you're gonna get fined a
thousand dollars which i'd love to see
if biden gets fined a thousand dollars
not only are you gonna get fined or i
guess the restaurant tour gets fined a
thousand dollars not the patron so we'll
find out about that um
but you know you probably optics wise
probably wouldn't be the best thing so
somebody there took video of them and
that's what a good citizen does because
these people don't care they do not
believe in their rules and i don't even
think joe biden really believes that
covet is real at this point i i think
that if he did that at his
age
and everything else they would be taking
no risks but we played the video last
week where biden and dr jill
walk out of the helicopter and they have
their masks on with their assistant and
the assistants walking with the mess
then she takes the mask off and it's
like you obviously all weren't wearing
the mask in the helicopter like we know
all of this stuff here's a little more a
little more from the post-millennial on
this on saturday night president joe
biden was caught maskless dining with
first lady jill biden inside the upscale
fiola marre restaurant in washington d.c
an apparent violation of the district's
indoor mask mandate dc still requires
all indoor diners to wear a mask unless
they're actively eating and drinking the
president was filmed walking around
without a mask when greeted by reporters
and by the public outside biden was met
with cheers and a soul question of how
was dinner mr president no reporters
questioned his lack of masking so look
you guys know this is all theater and
and dribble and nonsense and has very
little to do with anyone getting sick or
not the idea that we go into restaurants
and when you sit at a table somehow
you're not going to catch covet but when
you go to the bathroom you should put a
mask on or when you're not actively
eating and drinking which is also what
they do on airplanes sitting somehow i
guess covet you know goes around five
foot seven is the average what's the
average height of a human being can i
get an average height of a human being
let's say about five eight something
like that
the covid must be floating around at
that level when you sit
what do we got what do we got when you
sit covet can't hit you i mean all of
these nonsensical things and biden knows
as mangled and marbled as his brain is
biden even knows that it's all sort of
nonsense the average height of a man
five foot six that is short that is oh
connor's very excited about that
congratulations mr average and the
average height of a woman five foot two
so i guess if you're above five foot six
you know people are breathing so if
you're five eight then why do you have
to wear a mask because they're breathing
it's going this way
you'd walk right past them anyway it's
all just it's all just theater and
nonsense